В ефірі новини «heute» з Мітрієм Зіріним.
Вітаю вас.
Крістін підготувала для нас головні новини спорту.
Буде багато цікавого.
Почався новий сезон Бундесліги, а ще маємо кілька медалей
на Чемпіонаті світу з веслування на байдарках і каное.
Добрий вечір. Так, футбольний сезон офіційно розпочато!
Детальніше згодом.
Отже, сьогодні у випуску:
Ескалація на Близькому Сході -
після потужного ракетного обстрілу палестинською
терористичною організацією «Ісламський джихад»
Ізраїль обстріляв сектор Гази.
Нова фаза в російсько-українській війні -
Росія стягує свої військові підрозділи на Південь.
Запорізька АЕС у небезпеці.
Хеві-метал назавжди! Найбільший в Німеччині
фестиваль важкої музики Wacken Open Air
повертається після дворічної перерви через пандемію
коронавірусу та збирає 75 000 глядачів.
Більше року ситуація між Ізраїлем та Палестиною
була порівняно стабільною.
Проте вчора затишшя скінчилося.
Армія Ізраїлю завдала авіаударів по сектору Гази.
Уряд назвав свої дії
«високоточною антитерористичною операцією».
За попередньою інформацією,
щонайменше дванадцять людей загинуло.
З Гази, у свою чергу, теж випустили чимало ракет
у бік Ізраїлю.
Детальніше про новий спалах насильства
розповість Андреас Кинаст.
Вони знають, що від сирени до
можливого авіаудару всього 30 секунд.
Тут, в Ашкелоні, як і в більшості Південних міст Ізраїлю,
люди провели цілу ніч в укриттях.
Вперше за більше ніж рік.
24 години тому з Гази вилетіли перші ракети,
жителі Півдня Ізраїлю могли спостерігати за тим,
як більшість із них було збито системами ППО.
Учора ізраїльські військові оприлюднили ці кадри:
авіаудар, внаслідок якого було ліквідовано частину
керівництва екстремістської організації «Ісламський джихад».
Зокрема, військового командира Тайсіра аль-Джабарі.
За даними палестинських ЗМІ,
є жертви і серед цивільних.
Зокрема, загинула п'ятирічна дитина.
Ситуація в лікарні складна.
Багато поранених у важкому стані,
четверо чи п'ятеро з них - у критичному.
У численних ракетних обстрілах із Гази
влада Ізраїлю звинувачує саме вбитого ватажка аль-Джабарі.
«Ісламський джихад» - друга за впливовістю
організація, ще радикальніша від «ХАМАСу».
До того ж, ще тісніше пов'язана зі ще одним
заклятим ворогом Ізраїлю - Іраном.
Ізраїль розпочав високоточну антитерористичну операцію проти
безпосередньої загрози для нашої країни - «Ісламського джихаду».
Але не проти народу Гази.
Сьогодні Ізраїль продовжив завдавати ударів
по головних установах «Ісламського джихаду».
Єгипет вже запропонував стати посередником
у переговорному процесі між Ізраїлем та Палестиною.
Маємо пряме включення з Тель-Авіву.
Проаналізуємо ситуацію з Андреасом Кинастом.
Андреасе, після достатньо довгого затишшя
ситуація в Газі знову вийшла з-під контролю,
обидві сторони налаштовані дуже рішуче.
Це черговий «обмін люб'язностями» між вороже налаштованими
країнами чи йдеться про початок справжньої війни?
Безумовно, страх війни відчутний.
Вперше за більше ніж рік тут, у Тель-Авіві, лунає
сигнал повітряної тривоги через загрозу ракетного удару.
Ми на власні вуха чули, як здетоновували снаряди
під час роботи системи протиповітряної оборони,
так званого «Залізного купола».
Чи буде розв'язана повномасштабна війна,
залежить не лише від Ізраїлю
та «Ісламського джихаду»,
а й від найвпливовішої палестинської
організації «ХАМАС».
Як не дивно, «ХАМАС» не причетний
до нещодавніх подій в Газі.
Уряд Ізраїлю сподівається, що так залишиться і надалі.
Сьогодні ввечері в Тель-Авіві відбудеться чергове
засідання Військово-політичного кабінету Ізраїлю,
яке має засвідчити готовність країни
продовжити операцію, якщо це буде необхідно.
Дякуємо за Вашу думку, Андреасе.
Це був Андреас Кинаст із Тель-Авіву.
Зважаючи на загрозу нових
перегонів ядерних озброєнь,
особливого значення набуває вшанування пам'яті
жертв ядерного бомбардування Хіросіми.
За хвилину мовчання японці згадують
усіх 140 000 жертв і кожного.
77 років тому Сполучені Штати вдарили по Хіросімі -
це було перше застосування ядерної зброї в історії.
У своїй промові Генеральний секретар ООН Антоніо Гутерреш
вкотре закликав світ відмовитися від ядерної зброї.
За словами Гутерреша, світ продовжує бавитися
«зарядженою зброєю».
МАГАТЕ попереджає про загрозу
ядерної катастрофи в Україні.
Ситуація на Запорізькій АЕС вийшла з-під контролю.
Вчора російські окупанти обстріляли АЕС.
У результаті влучання снаряду
один із реакторів вийшов із ладу.
Запорізька АЕС має 6 енергоблоків, а отже
є найбільшою в Європі.
Запорізька АЕС почала свою роботу
в середині 1980-х років.
У березні АЕС захопили російські війська.
Згідно з Міністерством оборони Великої Британії,
Москва масово перекидає свої війська
на Південний Захід -
паралельно річки Дніпро, у напрямку Запоріжжя.
Далі розповість Ніна Ніберголл.
Над найбільшою атомною електростанцією в Європі
нависла темна хмара диму.
Якби стався витік водню
або розпилення радіоактивних частинок -
наслідки були б жахливими.
Сьогодні окупанти створили чергову надзвичайно
ризиковану ситуацію для всіх у Європі.
Вони обстріляли Запорізьку АЕС.
Будь-які обстріли цього об'єкту - це відвертий,
зухвалий злочин, акт терору.
В Україні повідомляють, що росіяни захопили
Запорізьку АЕС ще в березні
та використовували її як військову базу
та надійний щит
у той час, як реактори все ще продовжували працювати.
Чи справді Росія обстріляла вже захоплений об'єкт?
Росія заперечує всі звинувачення та, навпаки, стверджує,
що саме українські військові здійснили 3 артилерійські
удари по Запорізькій АЕС та місту Енергодар.
Багато жителів Енергодару працювало на АЕС.
Деякі продовжують працювати й зараз, в окупації.
Однак тепер їм страшно.
Там дуже небезпечно.
Це може бути другий Чорнобиль або навіть гірше.
На щастя, під час березневих обстрілів Запоріжжя росіяни
не пошкодили жодного енергоблоку.
Експерти з атомної енергетики попереджають,
що станція та її обладнання вже застарілі,
тому бої поблизу АЕС є вкрай небезпечними.
Військові експерти теж занепокоєні.
Російські військові використовують АЕС
передусім як склад боєприпасів,
а, як ви знаєте, останні кілька тижнів українська армія
систематично обстрілювала російські склади.
Тому ми дуже сумніваємося, що росіяни обстрілювали вже
захоплену АЕС, ризикуючи власними життями.
Товсті бетонні стіни теж добре
захищають АЕС від обстрілів,
однак потужного вибуху вони
можуть не витримати.
Як продовжувати вести нормальне життя,
коли у твоїй країні триває війна?
Більшість українців сподіваються,
що ситуація стабілізується
та живуть у постійному страху
російських авіаударів.
Наша журналістка Анне Брюль
побувала на Півдні України.
Вона поділиться своїми враженнями про життя
в невеликій церковній парафії
на Миколаївщині, усього за кілька кілометрів
від лінії фронту.
Ці люди молять Бога про допомогу та заступництво
в страшні воєнні часи.
Ми побували на ранковій службі однієї
з греко-католицьких церков Миколаєва.
З міркувань безпеки богослужіння відбувається в підвалі.
Наші сини на фронті.
Ми віримо в небеса, віримо в Бога
і віримо в те, що наш народ нарешті стане вільним.
Ти не знаєш, прокинешся зранку чи ні,
влучить ракета чи не влучить.
Під час богослужіння по місту завдали
черговий авіаудар.
З церкви добре видно сірі клубні диму
над місцем влучання ракети.
В громаді роздають гуманітарну
допомогу від фонду «Карітас»,
профінансовану за рахунок пожертв,
зокрема, і з Німеччини.
Дякувати богу, нам допомагають
Європейські країни.
Але я б сказав, що це їхній обов'язок,
адже якщо Україна не вистоїть,
війна прийде до Європи.
Священник взяв нас із
собою на зустріч із біженцями,
які потребують продуктів харчування.
Ми зупиняємося біля місця влучання,
прямісінько перед житловим будинком.
Любов Ставицька вже чекає на нас.
Вона розповіла нам, що через її рідне село
зараз проходить лінія фронту.
Спочатку тут було трішки спокійніше,
але тепер вибухи чутно і тут.
Нам страшно. Ми вже просто не витримуємо.
Сховатися ніде.
Завдяки пожертвам «Карітас»
Любов отримала рис, боби та олію.
Але найбільше Любові та її землякам бракує миру. Його
в Миколаєві, на жаль, не відшукаєш у жодній гуманітарці.
Лише за рік після передчасного та хаотичного
виведення військ НАТО з Афганістану
17 556 афганців та їхніх рідних емігрувало
до Німеччини.
Про це повідомляє газета «Welt am Sonntag»,
посилаючись на офіційні джерела.
Ще 6000 осіб отримали дозвіл на вʼїзд.
Виведення збройних сил Бундесверу з Афганістану
спровокувало шквал серйозних звинувачень
проти федерального уряду,
тому що багато місцевих солдатів-іноземців, що служили
з німецькими солдатами, і досі залишаються в Афганістані.
Німеччині взимку не уникнути проблем із постачанням газу,
тому вже сьогодні політики наполегливо закликають заощаджувати.
Президент Федерального мережевого
агентства, Клаус Мюллер, в одному з інтерв'ю повідомив,
що щонайменше 20% газу мають заощадити споживачі.
Захисниця прав споживачів Рамона Поп
також закликає заощаджувати
та збільшити допомогу для людей з низьким доходом.
Газу в Німеччині стало менше, а от дискусій
щодо продовження строків експлуатації АЕС все більшає.
Наразі функціонують три ядерні реактори.
Серед них - Неккарвестгаймська АЕС,
що розташована у землі Баден-Вюртемберґ.
Те, що політики знову говорять про продовження строку
експлуатації АЕС, дає жителям надію
на подальший успішний розвиток економіки.
Репортаж Антона Яні.
Атомна електростанція мало не на порозі будинку.
Так з 1970-х живуть громадяни швабської громади
Неккарвестгайм,
що в районі Гайльбронн.
Електростанція німецької енергетичної
компанії EnBw роками збагачувала громаду.
А муніципалітет, за словами мера, завжди вкладав
у розвиток міста.
Завдяки цьому ми могли фінансувати проєкти,
які інакше такому маленькому містечку були б не під силу.
Багато з них мають надрегіональне значення.
Це був час розквіту громади.
Тепер зазіхати на вершини не вийде,
бо основне джерело доходу - АЕС - висохло.
І більшість підприємців, як от Гольгер Морлок,
давно почали пошук нових клієнтів.
Про закриття АЕС говорили вже давно.
Кожен підприємець має бути готовим до змін
і пристосовуватися до них.
Навіть якщо ми втратимо такого потужного клієнта,
то хтось постраждає більше, хтось - менше.
АЕС годувала
багато місцевих сімей.
Тож шукати противників атомної
енергетики тут марно.
А дискусії щодо продовження строку експлуатації АЕС
вселили надію.
Я підтримую продовження експлуатації.
Адже через дефіцит енергоносіїв, газу,
проблем не уникнути.
Я вважаю, що
АЕС нам ще знадобиться.
Ви зовсім не боїтеся?
Ні, я прожив тут 30 років.
І нічого ще не трапилося.
Та все ж Неккарвестгаймській АЕС залишилося недовго,
мова йде про місяці.
Проте демонтаж може тривати десятиліттями.
Це знаменує початок нової епохи маленького
містечка в районі Гайльбронн,
де займаються виноробством.
Після пандемічної перерви у Гамбурзі
знову відбувся ЛГБТ-прайд «Christopher Street Day».
До того ж, з рекордною кількістю учасників.
За словами організаторів, до заходу доєдналося
близько чверть мільйона людей.
Попри барвисте вбрання, святковий настрій
та найкращу літню погоду,
учасники піднімають важливу проблему.
Їхній девіз - «Виходь на вулиці!
Різноманітність замість насильства».
Вони вимагають для людей квір більше захисту
від залякування і ненависті.
Вакен - ідилічне містечко далеко на півночі з населенням
майже 2000.
Та раз на рік воно перетворюється
на грандіозний фестиваль важкого металу.
Організатори говорять про неймовірну
кількість учасників
цьогорічного фестивалю - 75 тисяч!
Після двох років пандемії гроші ллються рікою,
також і в кишені місцевих жителів.
Для них важкий метал вже давно став
соціально прийнятним явищем.
Репортаж Клааса Томсена.
Фестиваль Wacken 2022, здавалося б, оазис серед пустелі
для любителів металу.
Два роки коронавірусу в минулому.
Тепер можна спокійно гендбенити,
танцювати чи просто покричати від радості.
Ваке-е-е-ен!
Цього року тут багато пилу.
Тож славнозвісних «болотних ванн» цьогоріч не буде.
Але це неважливо - головне бруд.
Тому що він є частиною концепту фестивалю.
Знаєте, чому я люблю цей фестиваль?
Бо можна кричати, як божевільний.
І моя мама про це не дізнається.
Ми три дні не спали, у мене майже зник голос.
І не приймали душ.
Через новий спосіб безготівкової оплати за пиво і картоплю фрі
було трохи хаосу та довгі черги.
Приїхати на місце подій можна було дещо потягом
або перонним автобусом.
Серце фестивалю в усьому:
у творчому хаосі на кемпінгах,
у вечірках з місцевими жителями,
у фольклорному оркестрі пожежної бригади
або у йозі в пилу на «святій землі» містечка Вакен.
Ми всі разом, кожен у гармонії з собою, немає стресу.
І якщо хтось впаде у натовпі - йому допоможуть піднятися.
Головне - люди, а музичні гурти то вже так, бонус.
Час побути самим собою, відключитися.
Кілька безладних серпневих днів стали для когось раєм на землі.
А ми переходимо до подій спорту.
Крістін розкаже про матчі Бундесліги.
Але спершу - про втішні новини чемпіонату світу з
веслування на байдарках і каное.
Наша збірна завоювала 5 медалей, але поки без золотої.
Перший фінальний день чемпіонату
відбувся у місті Галіфакс, Канада.
Німецький флот виборов 2 срібні та 3 бронзові нагороди.
А популярна четвірка чоловіків
цьогоріч зазнала поразки.
Перше місце вибороли їхні суперники з Іспанії.
Яких вони торік перемогли на олімпійських іграх
у Токіо, тоді до команди входив Рональд Рауе.
А зараз у складі команди Йоганес Шопф, Маск Рендшмідт,
Том Лібшер та Макс Лемке.
Все ж німці наздоганяють і посідають друге місце
у турнірній таблиці перед Україною.
Іспанія сьогодні непереможна.
Команда Німеччини значно відстає.
Срібло завоював Ніко Пікерт з Лейпцига.
У неолімпійській дистанції 24-річний здобуває свою
першу медаль на чемпіонаті.
Він лише на декілька секунд відстає
від свого супротивника з Польщі - Олексія Колядича.
0,10 секунди не вистачає німцю
для перемоги у його першому бою за титул.
Вчора блискуче зіграв ФК «Баварія» (Мюнхен).
Рахунок 6:1.
Сьогодні своєю грою вражає ФК «Фрайбург».
Розглянемо турнірну таблицю.
Матч «Аугсбург» - «Фрайбург» завершився з рахунком 4:0.
У берлінському дербі «Уніон» - «Герти».
З рахунком 3:1 перемагає «Уніон».
Чудовий старт для Даніеля Фарке.
«Боруссія Менхенгладбах» - «Гоффенгайм» 3:1.
«Вольфсбург» і «Вердер» зіграли в нічию - 2:2.
«Бохум» поступається «Майнцу» - 1:2.
Про матч «Дортмунд» - «Баєр 04 Леверкузен»
поговоримо у випуску «Sportstudio».
Минулої ночі ФК «Айнтрахт» зазнав фіаско
у матчі з «Баварією».
За кількістю голів ФК «Баварія» наразі немає рівних.
Завтра відбудеться матч «Штутгарт» - «РБ Лейпциг» та
«Кельн» - «Шальке». Повернення «Шальке».
Після поразки чемпіону і перед Суперкубком УЄФА
проти ФК «Реал Мадрид» до студії випуску
«aktuelles Sportstudio» о 23:30
навідається тренер
франкфуртської команди «Айнтрахт» Олівер Гласнер.
А також зірки жіночого футболу:
тренерка національної збірної
Мартіна Восс-Текленбург і воротарка Мерле Фромс.
В Англії стартувала Прем'єр-ліга.
Досить скромний старт сезону для Юргена Клоппа
та ФК «Ліверпуль».
Ліверпульці спершу не витримали тиску ФК «Фулхем».
Двічі допустили гол у свої ворота.
Допоки на 80-й хвилині Мохаммед Салах не забив гол,
зрівнявши рахунок - 2:2.
«Найкраще в цій грі - це результат!» -
так вважає тренер Юрген Клопп.
Тепер можна дещо видихнути.
Що ж, їм просто пощастило.
Дякую!
Завтра буде тепло та сонячно.
Детальніше про погоду розповість Кріста Орбен.
Випуск «heute journal» з Крістіаном Зіверсом сьогодні о 23:15.
Ми повернемося завтра.
Дякуємо за перегляд і бажаємо
спокійного суботнього вечора.
Добрий вечір.
Сьогодні вночі було достатньо прохолодно.
У гірському регіоні Зауерланд сьогодні вранці,
перед сходом сонця, було 5°C.
Це на 3°C холодніше, ніж учора.
У місті Квітборн, Шлезвіг-Гольштейн, вчора було +10°C,
а сьогодні вранці +6°C.
І в Райнштеттені, що в районі Карлсруе,
не залишилося ані сліду
від вчорашньої тропічної ночі.
Цієї ночі скористайтеся нагодою провітрити приміщення
та охолодитися,
адже температура знизиться до +8-15°C.
Злива на південному сході стихає,
поступово прояснюється.
Хмарно буде у Шлесвіг-Гольштейні
та на території Балтійського моря.
Все ж переважно без опадів.
На інших територіях - сонячно.
На півдні завтра після обіду спостерігатиметься купчаста
хмарність, але без опадів. На півночі +20-25°C.
На півдні +23-29°C. На південному заході +30°C.
Крім того, завдяки антициклону очікується підвищення температур
та сонячна погода.
На кадрах графік змін температур у Кельні. Там очікується
до +35°C вдень та +20°C вночі.
На цьому в мене все. Бувайте!